you said something really funny actually  um a few years ago when you had nothing  and you were living in america  they couldn't help you but as soon as  you left the irs knew how to get hold of  you they knew how to call you okay they  know how to find your ass when you owe  them money yeah but it's never you know  like if they owe you money it takes  months and months and months to turn up  if ever right but if you owe them money  it's like woohoo you better pay us the  whole thing is a scam it's like the  entire financial system which we can  discuss at length our entire financial  system is designed to steal wealth from  the poor and just turn it into numbers  on the screen of construction by design  yeah oh yeah the whole thing is corrupt  and when you understand the system you  understand that the system is rigged to  a point where most people do not stand a  chance to ever ever win the leia  milestone show